i'm pamela mcgee aka mama mcgee the
first
mother olympian to birth an olympian how
you doing i'm javille mcgee aka three
times
three three-time nba champion one time
gold medals and we're playing moms knows
best
[Music]
[Music]
but i'm the better athlete that's what
that means what do you mean
[Music]
he's teaching me social media
he's teaching me about instagram
twitter i'm gonna teach her to stop
posting the same picture over and over
again
i love keeping me
i just don't cook but i can cook better
for sure
okay well but but if you don't cook that
means i'm the better club because that's
true
that's like saying i'm a better player
and i never play quality is quality not
quantity
oh yeah
some cake so hawaii
i'm the i'm the vacation player yeah
that's the man right there
he he comes up with like the best one is
our mcgee family retreat we have 50
people in hawaii
and he literally planned it like a
like a tour guide we had a bus
we had like exercises we had events
hiking hiking we had to go up this
mountain
and i mean everything it was planned
when we got off the trip we went we had
the mcgee we had a mcgee island we had
to swim to the mcgee island man that was
the best trip ever
uh i'd probably say her
oh gonna look right it's different
though you're forced to shoot jump shots
though because you can't look good
looking out
me for sure
he does i mean he listens to
like i mean i think he has like 8 000
songs on his play whatever in his itunes
whatever so he's he and he turns me on
why you should hear this uh like i
listen to something in his car and i you
know shazam it
so he really exposed and then some of
his own music that he produces
category bad am i embarrassing you
you're all good man